- Hello, Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems,
so to help you on your journey today,
I'm going to talk about seven ways
to improve your people skills.
(electronic music)
So, I often get asked, from entrepreneurs,
how do I improve my people skills?
Evan, I need help,
either with my customers,
either when I'm marketing,
and going out to trade
shows, or I'm meeting people,
or I'm with my team, how
to be a better leader.
How do I improve my people skills?
And so, I thought I'd make this video,
sharing seven different
ways I think will help you
in your challenge.
So, tip number one, is decide
what you want to improve.
There's a lot of different
things around people skills,
and if you want to improve at all of them,
it can be a challenge, and
you may not even want to.
So, having focus gives you clarity,
and allows you to really improve.
So, as an example, do you want to improve
your networking skills?
Do you want to improve
your leadership skills?
your social setting skills?
You know, what is it exactly
that you want to improve,
and we can figure that out.
And just focus on the
one most important thing,
like maybe you really want
to be a better leader,
but you don't really care that
much about the networking,
or maybe you don't even have a team yet.
You don't care about leadership skills.
Maybe, all you want to
do, is get more sales,
and you're going to events,
and you want to learn how to shake hands,
and make a connection
really quick with people.
Figure out exactly what it
is that you want to learn.
If you can get that focus and clarity,
it's much more easier
to make rapid progress,
achieving your goal.
Step number two, is model success.
And this is always a go-to for me.
If you don't know what you're doing,
if you're trying to learn something,
one of the fastest ways to do it,
is find someone who's already
done it, and learn from them.
Instead of you struggling,
and trying to figure it out,
learn from someone's who's
already gone out and done it.
It'll massively shortcut
your path to success,
and you may not even figure it out
most of the things that you're trying,
until you get that
input from someone else.
And so, again, having the clarity,
I want to be a master networker, great.
Who is a master networker in your eyes?
Go to YouTube, look at different videos.
You can read different books,
you can attend conferences.
Find the master networker!
Or, I don't care about networking,
I care about leadership!
Great, who are the leadership experts?
How can I hang around them?
How can I be with them,
as much as possible?
Going to their events,
reading their books,
being around them, watching their videos?
And I would highly encourage you
not just to read content, not
just to look at the how-tos,
because everybody will have,
here are the seven ways to do it!
Rhetorically, will have their list.
But, to feel it, to see
how they do it, right?
So, if I'm making a video about
how to write a book, right?
Don't just watch the video
about how to write the book,
watch me document the process.
I mean, I don't know how many videos.
I made over 50 videos,
documenting the process.
Watch that,
or watch somebody else
going through the process.
Having the how-to videos is
great, it's a starting point,
but a lot of the content
is also going to come,
by just watching them.
So, just reading an article about
how to make an introduction to somebody,
versus watching somebody, who's
really good at it, doing it,
and demoing it, and showing it,
and guiding other people through it,
you'll learn a lot more
through that process,
than just by reading an article.
And so, when you clearly
identify, back to step one,
clearly identify what it is
that you want to work on,
then go off of model success,
find a person who's the genius at it,
and try to be around them.
Go to their event, see them do
it live, watch their videos,
and get their books,
and read their content,
but I want you to see it, and feel it,
'cause when you can feel
it on an emotional level,
and not just understand it, up here,
you're much more likely to
retain it, and take action.
Tip number three, practice,
practice, practice,
like anything else!
You want to get better at
somethin', you got to practice!
You got to dedicate time to
it, consistently, every day,
to practice, to get better, to improve.
So, we've identified what
it is about people skills
we want to work on.
We've modeled success,
and found the best people in the world
that are doin' it.
We've attended some of their events,
we've watched their videos,
we've read their books,
great, that's just knowledge!
It's not going to actually happen
'til you do somethin' about it.
You can understand how do to
do a jump, on a snowboard,
but you're not going to
get the muscle memory
and actually be able to
perform it, until you practice,
and you're going to fall,
and fall, and fall, and fall,
and get better and practice.
And so, whatever it is
that you improve on,
you got to put in the reps.
I've made 5,000 videos, on
this YouTube channel, right?
1,000 of them are not even public.
Though, 1,000 videos, which
is more than most people do,
in general, on a YouTube channel,
that are not even public.
I've just brought Lily
on board, on my team,
if you've watched Unlocking
Lily series, and right now,
I'm filling up her schedule.
When she does an Unlocking Lily video,
her first video, it took
over 100 takes, each time,
to get that best version.
And she'll spend every
Friday, the whole day,
filming, filming,
filming, filming, filming,
hundreds of takes.
And if you've watched her first video,
she only got three videos.
Her first, to the second, to the third,
you'll see that she's gotten
way better in each one,
but she's put in the work.
And so, I'm filling up her schedule.
I'm giving her interviews, I'm
giving her coaching sessions.
I'm giving her entrepreneurs to talk to.
I'm giving her opportunities to speak,
opportunities to be in the video.
Her schedule is just rammed, full, right?
She came here, and she did
two videos with me, today,
filming day, and she just came
back from a coaching calling
interview, then she had to rush back,
to do more coaching
calls, more interviews,
the whole day is full,
because she's puttin' in the reps!
'Cause, she's really good now,
but to get great, to get
to where she wants to be,
to build a million dollar business
around speaking and coaching,
that she wants to do,
that I'm here to help her with,
she's got to put in
repetitions, to get better.
And so, practice, whatever you learn,
whatever that thing is, that
you pull from that expert,
that you want to learn, you
got to put in the practice,
and find somebody to work.
So, if it's networking, great,
you've learned the skill,
now go out and practice!
Going to one networking event a month
is not going to do it!
You got to, multiple events, per week.
Practice networking on the subway.
Like everyday, you want to
hone your skills of practice.
If it's about rapport building,
maybe you learn about
how to match and mirror,
and so, you're learning
matching body language, right?
If somebody's goin' like this,
you kind of go like this.
If somebody's arms crossed,
then you start with your arms crossed,
and you try to lead them,
to get them to have their arms open.
It's when you know you've
established some rapport.
Matching and mirroring.
Great, practice that!
Practice it with your family,
practice it with your friends,
even without telling 'em!
You're just practicing!
And sometimes, you're going to fail,
especially at the beginning.
You will suck.
A lot of these methods won't work
quite as you expect them to,
because you're just
starting out, and you suck.
Expect that to happen.
How you get better, is you
practice, practice, practice,
practice, practice.
'Cause, you have the knowledge.
You know what you're supposed to do,
but you can't actually do it yet.
You get it, by putting the
work, doing the practice,
and building a muscle.
- We got it, we're in?
Awesome.
Misfit Nation has just
taken over Seven Ways.
Hi, everyone, my name is Dave Lukas.
I'm the host of the Misfit
Entrepreneur podcast,
and we are tackling number four,
in Seven Ways, in people skills this week.
The answer I have for you is
actually a two-part answer,
and the first part is actually something
that I learned from a mentor of mine,
that ran a Fortune 100 company,
and I learned it many years ago.
And it goes like this.
If you want to know what John Smith buys,
you have to see things
through John Smith's eyes.
And what that means, is
that you really need to
put yourself in the other person's shoes.
You really need to understand
what motivates them,
what drives them, what they care about,
what the levers are, that
really drive their decisions,
and why they do things.
Once you understand that,
and understand what they
want out of something,
then it makes it that much easier,
to get what you want, or
be able to get the outcome
that you're looking for,
whether you're negotiating a deal,
putting together a big project,
or just want to work better with somebody.
The second part of this,
there's actually a concept
made famous by Zig Ziglar,
and that goes like this,
if you help somebody get what they want,
you'll get what you want, and more,
and really, it's the law of reciprocity.
So, the more that you are
focused on helping others
get what they want, and
accomplish the things they want,
you'll be amazed at what it does for you.
It'll come back to you tenfold.
So, when you pair those two together,
really understanding what
drives someone, motivates them,
and then looking for the best
way to help them get there,
and make it mutually
beneficial, everybody wins,
and that's the important thing.
So, that's number four,
in Seven Ways, this week.
Hopefully, you can take that,
and put it to work in your life right now,
and make a big difference.
Thank you.
- Tip number five is find
something you're curious about.
The easiest conversation
to have with somebody,
the easiest way to connect
with somebody else,
is through some kind of joint love.
So, if you can find somethin'
that you are genuinely curious about,
then it's way easier
to have a conversation.
It's way easier to get to know them.
So, for example, for me,
anything around entrepreneurship,
I am generally going
to love to talk to you.
If I find out that you're an entrepreneur,
we are going to have
an amazing discussion.
It's just going to happen.
You will, immediately,
perk up my excitement,
and I'm going to want to
challenge you, talk to you,
understand you, see how I can help you,
Even if we only have
five minutes together,
I want to be able to provide value,
and get you on your path.
It's just who I am.
And so, try to find some
kind of common ground,
between you and the other person.
It'll really help.
Now, you could do, if you know in advance,
anything about that person,
you can stalk them on Twitter,
and Instagram, and Facebook,
and YouTube, and just kind
of understand a little bit
about them, what they
may be interested in,
and you don't want to lead with,
hey, I saw that you loved
horseshoes, on Twitter!
That's awesome!
Tell me about horseshoes!
'Cause, if you don't actually
care about horseshoes,
then it's a disconnect,
and it's kind of creepy stalker scary,
so you don't want to let them know
that you've been following
them along on Twitter.
But, if you find something
that's generally interesting,
that's the key.
And so, you can start,
if you don't know anything about them,
you could start an event.
Well, how did they come to this event?
You're both at this event.
What motivated them to come here?
How do they know the host?
How did they find this place?
Did they search for it online?
What were their reasons for coming here?
That opens up a discussion,
and then, you're looking for
ways to generally be curious
about the other person.
If you can find any kind of
genuine connection there,
then it's easy to get them
to talk about themselves,
and it's easy to form that rapport.
Tip number six, is understand their why.
People love talking about themselves,
and I love getting people excited.
So, when I'm talking to entrepreneurs,
I like understanding why
they started their business.
Because, I want to get them pumped up.
If you are talking about something
that is meaningful to you,
that on a deep, emotional level,
it gets you feeling excited,
like this is your purpose,
then it's so much easier to follow through
on a conversation.
If I'm talking to an entrepreneur,
I ask them, why they
started their business.
And they tell me this story,
about this deep, meaningful connection,
to this product they're making,
or service they're making,
and they started because of their parents,
or whatever that backstory is.
There has to be something there
that fueled them to want to do this thing.
And whether it shows up to this event,
or choose that career
path, or marry that person.
Whatever it is, if you
understand their why,
and get them excited about it,
it's much more easy to form
a bond, and a connection.
When people ask me my why,
and they genuinely care about it.
If you have to actually
care, you can't just fake,
and say, so, why did you do this?
With genuine curiosity,
why do you do this thing?
It's awesome.
You'll get, if you ask me,
that you get me being excited,
if you get me telling an
excited story, like I am now,
then I'm much more likely
to connect with you,
and much more likely to want
to do business with you,
much more likely to want to refer you,
and much more likely to
take whatever action it is
that you want me to take,
even if it's just get to know each other,
exchange contact information.
Whatever it is, if you can get somebody
to explain their why,
on an emotional level,
because you generally care about it,
then it's much more
easy to build a rapport.
And tip number seven, is
help them with their goals,
and this builds off of what Dave,
from Misfit Entrepreneur, was saying.
You want to try to help
them accomplish what it is
that they're trying to accomplish.
I'd like to say, internally in my team,
that the most dangerous
thing that you can do,
is tell me what your goal is.
'Cause, as soon as I
know what your goal is,
what your dream is, now it's on my radar,
and I'm going to try to
make it happen for you,
and I'm going to push
you, to go off and do it.
And when you say, that you can't do it,
because of XYZ, and whatever
limiting beliefs you have,
we're pushing through those things, baby!
It's going to happen.
And so, I try to do that
with everybody I meet.
It's not even a strategy,
it's just natural.
Just what I try to do.
I don't even think about it,
but now that we're kind of making a list
of seven things to do,
it's one I think can be highly,
highly, highly effective.
When I went to ClamourCon recently,
it was an event for YouTubers,
one of my main things was
every time I met somebody,
I tried to introduce them to somebody else
that could help.
So, there was Sean,
from Video Influencers,
who was tryin' to interview YouTubers.
And I asked him, how many he had set up?
Like, what's your goal?
What are you tryin' to accomplish?
How many people are
you tryin' to interview
while you're here?
And he had this target.
Like, how many have you done so far?
And then, he's here.
Great, if I find somebody that's relevant,
do you want me to introduce you?
"Yes, that'd be amazing!"
Awesome!
So, every time I met an entrepreneur,
a YouTuber who had certain channel size,
I thought might be a
fit for Sean's channel,
I've watched Sean's videos,
so I know what it's all about,
I would introduce them.
And Sean is happy, and the
other entrepreneur is happy,
'cause they're getting exposure.
And I'm happy that I was
able to make that connection.
It was to the point, where
Charlie, from Chris on Command,
one of the channels that I love watching,
I met him at ClamourCon.
I introduced him to Sean.
He's going to be a guest,
on Video Influencers.
Charlie, then, went to his channel.
He made a video about how
to network, as an introvert,
which was me,
and the video's basically about me,
and my strategies at ClamourCon,
and how amazed he was
at all the connections
that I was able to make,
despite not really
knowing a lot of people.
And a lot of us, just based on this,
it's not that I'm some genius,
it's just I meet somebody,
I understand their why,
I ask questions about them.
I try to figure what their goal is,
not from a strategic point of
view, it's just how I think.
And then, I just keep that in my head.
This person is trying to accomplish this.
I meet somebody else,
and huh, you guys might,
do you know Charlie?
Do you know Sean?
Do you know this guy?
I just try to make those
natural connections.
It's just something that,
I think if you do it,
if you try to help other
people with their goals,
it's always going to come back to you.
It may not be in a way that you recognize,
or that is immediate, but it comes back.
Another quick example, on my
trip to LA, not too long ago,
I took my TDS team to
see Tony Robbins in LA,
and I sit back an extra
day, to do meetings.
I had a meeting with Brian Grazer,
the legendary Hollywood producer.
His assistant reached out to me,
'cause Brian wanted to meet
with me, on one-on-one.
I met with Lewis Howes,
later on that afternoon,
from School of Greatness,
and I was on his YouTube channel.
We did an interview there.
You guys can check it out.
It's pretty fun.
And I had other couple of
meetings, met with fans,
and then I came back.
Two weeks ago, I was watching
a video on Lewis's channel,
with Wyclef Jean,
and Wyclef, from the Fugees,
was talking about Brian Grazer,
and saying, "This guy
is one of the top guys,
"in Hollywood history,
"and someone who you need
to have on his show."
And Lewis was saying,
"Yeah, wow, that sounds
really interesting."
I wrote to Lewis, and said, hey, Lewis,
I saw Wyclef on your show,
he name dropped Brian Grazer.
You looked interested.
I actually met Brian a couple
hours before I met you,
when I was in LA.
I can set up the intro if you want,
and see, maybe where that goes.
And he said, "That would be amazing!
"Thank you so much!"
And so, I introduced Lewis
to Brian's assistant,
and maybe something happens,
maybe something doesn't happen.
Maybe it doesn't work out.
Maybe they become mortal
enemies, who knows.
But chances are, they're going to connect,
something's going to work out,
and both Lewis and Brian will be grateful
that I was the one who
made that connection.
Now, I'm not keeping scores.
It's not like, hey, Lewis,
I intro'd you to Brian,
so now you owe me this,
for my book, or my whatever.
That's not really how it works.
It's not really about keeping scores.
But, one, it just feels
good, to help people.
And two, if you help
people, and it's consistent,
then it comes back to you.
It just always does.
And so, when you're talking to people,
understand what their main goals are.
What are they trying to accomplish?
What are their dreams?
And to think, how can I help them?
And maybe an introduction,
and maybe just giving them a
push, beyond their limitations.
It may just be believing in them.
It may just be checking, and
seeing how they're doing.
Finding ways to help them
accomplish their goal
makes a huge, huge, huge difference.
So, those are my seven ways
on how to prove your people skills.
I made this video, because
Amervim Bonano asked me to.
So, if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover,
in a future Seven Ways video,
check out the link in the description,
and go and cast your vote,
'til you're going to win,
and we'll see some content coming soon.
I'd love to know, what did
you think of this video?
What was your favorite tip?
What are you going to immediately apply,
somehow to your life, or to your business?
Is there any idea, that you
want to add to the list,
that I missed?
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm really curious to see
what you guys have to say.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Dave Lukas,
from the Misfit Entrepreneur.
Dave, thank you so much
for being in this video,
as well as posting the picture of my book,
while you're on the beach.
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the read.
So, thank you guys, so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see ya soon.